the other day a colleague of mine a
really good science writer offered to
send me an advanced look of his next
book and he said he could send it either
as a pdf or as a kindle file and i
thought wow how civilized what a great
thing it is to live in the future where
you can actually get an electronic book
and look at it on these devices that
millions of us carry now
but it got me thinking about the
differences in the ways that i've
started to think about
electronic books and physical books
physical books and virtual books
so as an example
the guy who founded the internet archive
brewster kale has announced that he's
going to build a collection of every
published book in the world
it's this super romantic milwaukee and
quest right he calculates there's
hundreds of millions of these and he's
never going to get all of them but he's
going to get tens of millions he says
and you
catalog them put them in a box put the
box into a cargo container put the cargo
containers into a temperature
climate-controlled humidity-controlled
warehouse and you leave them there
so why do you do that well you do it my
argument i guess would be in case the
power goes off right i mean our tablets
our devices
in the end are limited by how much
electricity they have in them now i got
yelled at about this at work um one of
my colleagues said you don't need every
book if the power goes off you just need
the one book the one that tells you how
to turn the power back on
but that actually gets at a kind of a
fundamental problem with the
transmission of information across time
right and there are a bunch of
interesting groups working on stuff like
this the long now foundation is one of
them but it reminds me one of my
favorite stories in the history of
technology
i don't actually know all the details of
this or even if in fact the story is
apocryphal or even remotely true so i
make up parts of this to make it into a
better story but just bear with me
because it'll be good there's this town
called lowell in massachusetts and
it's still there it's a nice town but
it kind of got its start as a as a mill
town it was one of the first places
where there were automated looms um and
this was really before electricity was
early and before steam even early
industrial revolution so what powered
these looms was um uh water their the
town was basically built up on this
network of canals and a river and that
would turn big cranks and the cranks
would turn belt drives up in the ceiling
and those would run the looms
but the problem they had was that
whenever there would be a storm
the river would overflow would destroy
the mill and so they were really worried
about this because they didn't know when
the next storm would be
so they had to figure out a way to
build a system that would gate the
canals but they would tell people how it
would work and they didn't know how to
give them the instructions because they
didn't know when it would happen
anyway decades later a century later
whatever the storm finally gets there
the people who run lowell are in a huge
panic they know that there's a gatehouse
that'll close these gates somehow but
they don't know how it works and
nobody's figured out how it works and
however long it's been finally they
crack open the lock they break it in the
gatehouse they play their lantern across
the inside and inside this gate house
sitting on top the main gate is a metal
plaque
and a hammer and a steel rod coming out
of the floor
and the metal plaque says take the
hammer hit the pin
right the simplest piece of instruction
you can imagine they go in they take the
hammer down they hit the pin and closes
the gate they save the city
okay so that's transmitting information
across time right
well
a while back my grandmother died my
grandmother was a
professor of library science at uc
berkeley she was a communist rabble
rouser she spoke half a dozen languages
she traveled all over the world she was
an amazing lady by the time she died she
was in a two-room apartment
that was
caked with books i i did a rough counter
with something like 20 000. i mean they
were wall-to-wall floor-to-ceiling
and
it was my job and the job of the rest of
my family to clean the place when she
died
and as i was doing it i realized that
you know
as she got older her her genius her
brilliant mind and her memory really
faded and and what she had constructed
with these books was a literal version
of physical version of what's called a
memory palace it was a a
memorization a mnemonic technique that
they taught like monks in the middle
ages where you would build a virtual
place a location in your head and you
would store memories
and
use those locations as a way to
recollect stuff
they did a riff on in the new sherlock
holmes series last season too
but grandma had built a physical memory
palace right those books were her memory
pals and it made me realize that my
books are like that at home too that i
have my books on shelves rigorously
organized because i'm my grandmother's
grandson
and they're my memory palace i use their
physical locations i use the look of
those books to remember what's in them
which makes it very hard to have an
electronic version
so what i've started to do is
make decisions about what books i'm
going to get electronically and what
books i'm going to get
physically
authors who i've already collected a
bunch of books by because i have that
nerd collector compulsion i buy those
books um i get a lot of books about
cities and urban theory and i like the
maps and i like to look at those and i
want to remember that information in a
certain way so i tend to buy those but
like almost all the new science fiction
is electronic
the new stuff for work is electronic my
comic books have gone almost completely
electronic
and that sort of brings me back to what
brewster kale is doing
because i feel like he doesn't trust
the mnemonic right he doesn't believe
that the virtual world that the bits
will provide a kind of information for
him will provide memory for him
i think i'm worried about something
different i'm not worried about
forgetting what's in those books i'm
worried about forgetting how to remember
what's in those books
i think for me there's always going to
have to be a difference between
the
information
and the artifact
you